hombre y quería ver si hay una conexión
entre el momento en el que un examen es
resuelto y la calificación promedio de
ese examen ella recolecta información de
todos los exámenes del año anterior y
ordenó las calificaciones promedio de
los exámenes de acuerdo con el periodo
en que se resolvieron cuál es la mejor
descripción de esta relación antes de
ponernos a ver todas las opciones que
aquí vamos a analizar lo que nos dice
esta gráfica en el eje de las x tenemos
el periodo o la hora de la clase en la
que se resolvieron los exámenes la
primera hora de clase la segunda hora de
clase tercera cuarta etcétera y en el
eje de las diez tenemos la calificación
promedio desde 10 20 30 hasta 100 veamos
tenemos aquí por ejemplo que en la
primera hora dos alumnos sacaron uno
casi sesenta y otro casi setenta como
que no muy buenas calificaciones en la
segunda hora hubo uno que sacó medio fue
a la calificación 40 y otra más de 75 en
la tercera hora pues hubo también quien
sacó 46 y otros
salió arriba del 70 y bueno estos dos
intermedios en la cuarta hora hubo uno
que sacó 55 y otros que sacaron más de
60 en la quinta ahora de nuevo hubo uno
que sacó 50 y otro que llegó casi el 80
y algunos intermedios en la sexta ahora
casi todos salieron en este rango del 50
al 55 en la séptima hora hubo uno de 50
y otros alrededor del 65 y en la octava
ahora también tenemos unos que están
alrededor del 50 y otro que está por
arriba del 65 bien a todos estos datos
no hay una tendencia que indique que los
alumnos sacan una buena calificación
promedio en particular en una hora o no
aquí tenemos muy variados en cada hora
tenemos alumnos que están con el
promedio alrededor del 50 o abajo del 60
o incluso arriba del 70 o casi el 80
entonces realmente aquí no puedo poner
una línea que modele toda esta
información ni hacia arriba ni hacia
abajo realmente esto yo no le veo
ninguna
y ahora vamos a ver las opciones
relación lineal positiva que es decir
mientras aumenta la variable en x
también aumente la de ella no aquí no
hay relación lineal negativa que cuando
aumente x se disminuya no tampoco se ve
ese patrón relación no lineal quiere
decir que no hay una línea pero si hay 7
relación entre lo que está en x con
respecto a lo que está en ya y no hay
relación que yo creo esta es la que nos
está representando esta gráfica vamos a
comprobar la respuesta en efecto no hay
relación